qu'est-ce qui se passe l'hiver vient
tout juste d'arriver mais les hôpitaux
au pédiatriques sont débordés depuis
plusieurs semaines beaucoup plus
d'enfants sont malades leur immunité
semble moins bonne à cause de la
pandémie moins bonne parce qu'ils n'ont
pas eu des rhumes pour développer leur
immunité les femmes enceinte n'ont pas
eu des anticorps pour protéger pour
transmis à leur bébé malgré tout en
début de matinée on profite ici d'une
rare à calmi à l'urgence ça peut
vraiment rapidement se détériorer la
situation
[Musique]
plus tard les choses basculent un enfant
est en danger frappé par une grave
détresse respiratoire je pense qu'on va
y aller de l'avant avec une intubation
une quinzaine de soignants se
précipitent à son chevet ça prend des
mains ça prend des cerveaux aussi autour
de cet enfant-là les patients qui sont
malades aussi de l'autre côté mais moins
malade vont devoir attendre
tranquillement dans la salle d'attente
les chaises se remplissent depuis
quelques semaines l'attente peut aller
jusqu'à 12 heures et plusieurs comme
Caroline sont ici parce qu'ils n'ont pas
de médecine de famille non c'est souvent
les urgences
des fois ont réussi à avoir un
rendez-vous là dans une clinique sans
rendez-vous là mais souvent ça va être
plus urgence ou d'autres comme Sarah qui
ne pouvaient pas attendre très longtemps
en appelant ce matin on me donne un
rendez-vous mardi mais moi j'étais
certaine que je devais voir un docteur
aujourd'hui sinon c'était l'urgence soit
ce matin soit cette nuit la pression est
forte tellement que des chambres
individuelles ont même été transformés
en chambre double plusieurs enfants sont
coincés à l'urgence faute de lit
ailleurs dans l'hôpital une vingtaine de
patients qui sont stérilisés ici qui
sont l'attente de lier à l'hôpital mais
en raison des étages qui sont tout à
fait plein des dessins intensifs aussi
qui sont plein beaucoup de patience sera
mars à rester à l'urgence les hôpitaux
pour adultes ont reçu l'ordre d'éviter
les transferts d'enfants vers les
hôpitaux ou pédiatriques oui l'enfant
est dans son ventre très malade mais on
l'a stabilisé il est allé au sens
intensifs l'équipe de l'urgence a sauvé
l'enfant atteint d'insuffisance
respiratoire mais avec la saison de la
grippe qui approche le personnel est
fatigué et bien des médecins souhaitent
qu'on recommence à utiliser les masques
à tout le moins dans les espaces fermés
mais je suis inquiet pour les mois à
venir il faut vraiment que la population
aussi essaie de faire la part des choses
et qu'on s'entraide pour prendre nos
enfants ici David gentil les radios
Canada Montréal